good morning John people will often say
down in the comments that I'm pretty
good at talking really fast and by now I
kind of agree I've had a lot of practice
but John there are a few secrets to
being able to talk really well really
fast one of them you can see here and
this outtakes video that we did in which
you see the number of times that we
screw up but another of the secrets has
to do with cadence and fricatives and
plosives and stops this has led me into
a bit of an obsession with tongue
twisters and that is why I know what a
sibilant fricative is a fricative is a
noise that you make by putting two parts
of your mouth very close together and
blowing air through them basically like
a horse or fricatives are one of those
complicating things that your mouth will
ever do even if you are thinking of
something dirty fricatives are more
complicated than that so when i say she
sells seashells by the seashore
i'm alternating between two very similar
sibilant fricatives and the difference
is so slight that my brain gets confused
about which one I should be doing next
which is why when I say the shells she
sells our seashore shells shells the
shell she shells she sells our seahorse
shell she's the shells she sells our
seashore shells which I've had much less
practice at I screw up so much
interestingly the things that your
tongue have to do play a part in tongue
twisters but it's probably more of a
mind twister than a tongue twister
people reading tongue twisters silently
actually take longer to read tongue
twisters than non tongue twisting
sentences I know it's weird
other figurative zhh are also hard like
but it's even harder when you're mixing
fricatives like each like fishermen like
the fishermen named Fisher who was
fishing for fish and a Fisher until a
fish with a grin pulled Fisher the
fishermen in now they're fishing for
Fisher and the Fisher that tongue
twister relies on more than fricatives
it also relies on homophones words that
are different but sound exactly the same
and then we have a thing that I cannot
find a name for and so I've been calling
pseudo phones
Suda phones are words that are similar
but not quite the same and if you say
them wrong everything explodes for
example my absolute favorite tongue
twister I slit the sheet the sheet I
slit in on the slitted sheet I sit the
pseudo phones in this case being slit
sheet and sit what's worse is that there
are several other pseudo phones like
seat and sleet and another one and the
more frequently you say those other
pseudo phones the more frequently you
accidentally jump to them while you're
talking about the saluted sheet the
reason why this is my favorite tongue
twister is because people always end up
being on the slitted sheet another
important note about this loaded sheet
is that it's entirely iambic meaning
that accented in non accented words
alternate and that almost every accent
falls on a pseudo phone I slit the sheet
the sheet I slit and on the slitted
sheet I sit which brings me to what it
I think is the most important point
about tongue twisters the recognized
hardest tongue twisters are things like
the sheiks sixth sick sheep but you
never hear about the sheik six six sheep
just having a dense forest of civil and
fricatives is you know that's hard but
it's not interesting so what is
interesting about tongue twisters why do
we do it why do we have them and why are
they prevalent in every single language
including American Sign Language finger
fumbler they have them in sign language
too you can analyze all day why tongue
twisters are hard but the reason why we
do them is because they're fun the thing
that our mouth and our vocal cords in
our diaphragm and her lungs all do
together to make words is really amazing
you could easily argue that it is what
makes us special as a specie when you
start doing tongue twisters you start to
understand and see how complicated and
beautiful interesting it all is which is
why I reached out to nerdfighteria on
Twitter and I asked people to give me
tongue twisters in their negative
language because even if you don't
understand what these people are saying
the things that their mouths are doing
are amazing so real quick I just wanted
to share a few of em become the bottom
button but nazim al-haqqani she layered
a little opal long still on Linda lon
Martin Lucci Meadville oppa lead leash
alert system that part knew about Nevada
had a veteran character utilitarian
select arrow I'm tell you but that sorry
Obama Tara Tara Tara Assessor special
Jesse knows about Jesse's on social
nothing you say so tastes a CG war safe
a phased xyg more fun Swanson
coffers and the front Athena for
forefront example be filed a fear
through enough I'm perfectly FFL if he
suffer more fun fonts and cavasso
you could see by watching this that
there's something Universal about tongue
twisters and it's not just sibilant
fricatives the r universal thing really
is humanity and that we enjoy having fun
there's some more non english tongue
twisters in my pants and john if you
don't have a copy of Fox in socks I'm
sending my copy for Henry John I'll see
you on Wednesday
thank you for the assistance of
professor of linguistics Joel Anderson
and also to his friend Ann for getting
him in touch with me and to all of you
in the comments who were shouting right
now that I must be punished for making a
video that is longer than four minutes I
must remind you of the nerdfighter
montage exception and thus I remain
punishment free now I have a final
tongue twister for you Betty botter
bought some butter but she said the
butters bitter if I put it in my batter
it will make my batter bitter but a bit
of better butter will make my
or better so she bought some better
butter better than the bitter butter and
she put it in her batter and her batter
was not bitter so twas Betty botter
bought a bit of better butter